So, I have been asked to talk about this CADENCE304 study, a randomized study between BGB16673
versus Piltobutynib in relapsed refractory CLR trial that started in October last year,
has not been completed yet and not been reported yet.
So, from that perspective, the talk will be short.
To my surprise, the talk will be even shorter because Dr. Ereda did an exceptional introductory
talk and actually with more updated data covered a lot of what I plan to say.
So, this trial is a battle between a degrader versus the latest inhibitor and Piltobutynib
is a non-covalent inhibitor that is designed to get past the equivalent inhibitor mutations.
However, it has its own set of problems with inhibitors that confer resistance to Piltobutynib
and BGB.
The degraders are designed to...
...to get past that, yet there are mutations that confer cross-resistance to both.
So, BGB16673, I think we don't have to introduce it because Dr. Ereda just did that.
Interestingly, it's also seen as penetrating.
It degrades both wild-type and mutant, and it is not affected by many of the covalent
and non-covalent BDK inhibitor mutations.
These are earlier data.
The actual data from ASH24, you saw the ASH25 data from Dr. Ereda, earlier responses across
different time points, dose points for the Phase 1 study showing excellent response even
at very light, small doses.
You saw the updated progression-to-survival curves by Dr. Ereda, overall response rate
94%.
So, there was a good start of the battle.
Interestingly, the inhibitor was really not affected by many of the BDK mutations listed,
as well as many other mutations that confer resistance and high-risk features in CLR.
So, that was a very promising finding in this Phase 1 study.
The Phase 1 study also included the Victor's transformation, and there were some patients
that...
12 patients were, at the time of that presentation, efficacy-available, and they were heavily pre-treated.
All patients had received a prior covalent BDK inhibitor, and overall response rate was
58.3%.
CR rate was 8.3%, so very low.
But five of the seven patients that had a response remained on treatment for at least six months,
so not exactly what you would expect for Victor's transformation.
I think that's a good start.
You should think about combinations with a compound like that.
So, of course, there has not been any head-to-head comparisons, but if you just look at the phase
of it, what is known from the Phase 1 data of the BGB compound, the pivotal trial for
Pitobutinib and a randomized study against standoff care, all these trials include very
heavily pre-treated patients with prior BDK inhibitor exposure and high-risk biologies
with deletion 17 and p3-femutase.
And the results are very similar.
So, the results are very similar.
The results are very similar.